[explosion sounds]
Wish I had something I could be like [crashing explosion sounds]
Hey guys, Kat here with a sp...
Kat here.
We are the same person.
Yeah we are.
Sup nerds?
Hi I'm Jules and I'm Jul...
Hello everyone
What cha gonna do with all that junk? All that junk in outer space?
This nanograding produces ba bar birefringence
bar hang on I had this before birefringence thank you
As Walter Range wote
After the first and second world wars, PT
bleh
They found that these fake papers tended to
have higher levels of linguistic ob ob obsu
that word
So they're bright but they're bah
Whoo alright! Ah there's a lot of fancy words
in this ath atherosclerosis you would not
think I have like four years of ancient languages
in me.
And refu
[Blowing raspberries]
ggaaahhh
Water... water... uh does anyone have some
water? At some point in that you should
Does after a while reading off the top prompter,
the words stop looking like words.
Words that I'm saying doesn't even make sense
huh! ha ha! words
Do you have a move you would like to share?
[Music ♫]
I used to drink energy drinks every single
day but I stopped because they made my heart
aww I have one line
But in a
what the blah I was doing so well!
But the majority of si
I hope there's a lot of b-roll to cover all
of the quick takes ok
Just leaning being cool, you know?
Welcome to DNews
Airplanes fly best high up in the air and
people breathe best when I punch them in the
face.
[Loud eating]
You don't need clapping.
And if the star was really really massive,
it leaves behind something called your momma
wwwhhaaa
[More loud eating]
And some women have even confessed that they've
experienced the most intense orga... gotta
get this one right.
Let me do that again without the booger.
bum bum bbbaaaaa
You're still rolling all rant right? Boom alright.
Just frown now.
That's your cry face?
Uh
Do it one more time, sorry.
Ah they like actually hurt my eyes!
Good good good keep it going!
Make lemonade!
I'm actually crying!
Stop talking though.
Look sadder, you're kind of smiling.
There we go, got it.
Hey Craig you wanna do that secret thing that
only bearded guys know about?
Uh yeah!
I love jamming out to a good song.
My mind expands beyond the universe and when
it hits the vagus nerves, that is the nerve
that connects from your mind to your heart
to your gut.
All the way through the insides of your veins.
Shape is hugely import.
The Bristol Stool Chart identifies seven shapes
your stool can take: little lumps, a lumpy sausage,
a cracked sausage, smooth like a banana, soft
blobs, fluffy and watery oh sh
Am I turning into a sloth?
When people leave comments about like " This
guys looks like Sid the sloth from Ice Age"
I like f yeah!
I wanna get like a Sid the sloth shirt.
I wish, I wish I could.
Let us know down below in the comments and
don't forget
How do you guys deal with constipation?
Let us know in the comments below and don't
forget to subscribe for more DNews every day
of the week I'm sorry I was just thinking
about the comments we're gonna get.
You know what I find painful?
Your freaking comments sometimes.Ouch!
NNOOOO
Byyeee!
Hit me up on twitter @cleomsf, I color...
I color?
Sometimes you color.
She colors things!
She just makes videos of coloring, it's really
good!
Soothing!
Let me know down in the comments below or
if you have a question go ahead and leave
it down there too and use the hashtag ask
DNews let me say that again cause I don't
like "Leave it down there".
That sounds awkward cause we just talked about
pubic hair.
You can catch me there too @lizzette with
two z's and two t's.
That was our sultry outro.
Good bye.
Double wink.
Umm it's called blinking.